THAT IS THE PEOPLE INSIDE OF THE
PLANT TO HELP THE PEOPLE INSIDE
OF THAT PLANT, BUT THAT IS THE
SITUATION AS WE SPEAK.
JULIA.
>> AND NOW, ON THE ONE OF THE
MOST WANTED RUSSIAN BUSINESSMAN
WHO IS STRONGLY DENOUNCING THE
WEST TO DO MORE TO STOP THIS
MASSACRE.
NIC ROBERTSON IS JOINING US NOW,
AND WE HAD A FRIEND OF ALEXEI
NAVALNY AND A MEMBER OF THE
ANTI-CORRUPTION REGIME, AND IF
THEY DENOUNCE THE WAR THAT THERE
MUST BE A WAY TO MAKE THEIR WAY
BACK, AND THIS IS WHAT TINKOV IS
DOING.
>> HE IS.
AND HE IS TALKING ABOUT A WAY
BACK FOR PRESIDENT PUTIN, AND HE
IS INCREDIBLY CRITICAL OF PUTIN,
AND SCATHING IN A WAY THAT NO
OLIGARCH IN THE ORBIT OF
PRESIDENT PUTIN IS SO FAR
CALLING THE WAR INSANE, AND
SAYING THAT THERE IS A TERRIBLE
ARMY, AND GENERALS ARE WAKING UP
FROM HANGOVERS AND REALIZING
THIS, AND THIS IS WHERE THE
CRITICISM IS DIRECT, AND SAYING
THAT THE ARMY IS A ERA OF
CIVILITY AND GROVELING AND
NEPOTISM IS WHAT HAS LED TO THE
FACT THAT THE ARMY CANNOT FIGHT,
AND THAT MAKING LOSSES, AND SO
HE IS LAYING THIS RIGHT AT THE
FEET OF PRESIDENT PUTIN, AND
CRITICIZING THE CIVIL SERVANTS
WHO ARE WORKING IN THE KREMLIN
SAYING THEY ARE AT SHOCK THAT
THEIR CHILDREN CAN'T GO IN SHOCK
ON THE FRENCH RIVIERA AND NOT
CLEAR IF HE IS TALKING ABOUT THE
RUSSIAN KREMLIN OR FOREIGN
MINISTERS, BUT THESE ARE THE MEN
WHOSE CHILDREN AND STEP CHILDREN
TRAVEL AROUND EUROPE, AND SO HE
IS TAKING AIM AT THE SECOND
LEVEL, BUT AT THE SAME TIME
TRYING TO FIND A WAY OUT FOR
PUTIN SAYING THAT THE WEST
SHOULD FIND A FACE-SAVING WAY
OUT FOR PRESIDENT PUTIN WHICH IS
GETTING TO THE CORE ISSUE HERE.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT PRESIDENT
PUTIN.
TINKOV UNDERSTANDS THIS.
IT IS NOT ABOUT ANYONE ELSE, AND
PUTIN IS STUCK IN THIS WAR THAT
HE CREATED ON THIS NARRATIVE
THAT HE CREATED.
BUT IT IS NOT CLEAR THAT PUTIN
IS GOING TO LISTEN OR PRECISELY
WHAT HE IS GOING TO DO TO
SILENCE TINKOV AND THIS IS NOT
THE MESSAGE THAT PUTIN WANTS
SPREADING AROUND RUSSIA NOW.
>> AND AN EYESORE WITH NEPOTISM,
AND SYCOPHANTCY AND THERE HAS TO
BE AN OFF-RAMP AND SOME WAY FOR
PUTIN TO SAY THAT HE HAS A WAY
OF SUCCEEDING HERE, AND HOW DOES
THAT LOOK AT THIS WAY, AND HOW
DOES THE WEST PROVIDE IT, AND
SHOULD THEY PROVIDE IT?
>> IT IS GOING TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT.
THE ISSUE OF WAR CRIMES AND
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST PRESIDENT
PUTIN AND HIS FORCES ARE
STACKING UP.
THEY HAVE INVESTIGATORS RIGHT
NOW, AND THE EUROPEAN UNION, AND
THE EUROPEAN COUNCIL PRESIDENT
IS IN KYIV RIGHT NOW TALKING
ABOUT HOW THE EUROPEAN UNION CAN
SUPPORT IN THE INVESTIGATION OF
WAR CRIMES AND OTHER THING, AND
AS THAT EVIDENCE IS MOUNTING UP,
IT IS HARD TO SEE AN
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY
CURRENTLY BACKING UKRAINE IN A
WAY THAT IS ECONOMICALLY OR IN
ANY OTHER WAY THAT RUSSIA SHOULD
GET OFF OF THE TERRITORY, AND GO
BACK TO PRE-FEBRUARY SITUATIONS,
AND SO AS LONG AS PRESIDENT
PUTIN CONTINUES THAT LEVEL OF
AGGRESSION THAT IS UNDER WAY,
AND THE FORCES ARE DISPERSED IN
FORCES THAT NEVER WERE BEFORE,
IT IS HARD TO SEE HOW ANYONE IN
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY CAN
FIND A FACE-SAVING WAY FOR
PRESIDENT PUTIN THAT DIDN'T LOOK
LIKE APPEASEMENT, AND THAT IS
TOUGH.
SO THE MOVE, IT SEEMS, IT HAS TO
COME FROM WITHIN RUSSIA